well hello there watching the press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages time to see what's
making the headlines with the political
editors of the daily mirror and the song
pippa crera and harry cole welcome to
both of you as ever though we turn our
attention first of all to the front
pages starting with the telegraph the
nhs overwhelmed the telegraph reports as
it attempts to deliver government
pledges on booster jabs
the guardian says the national health
service has been put on a crisis footing
as hospitals in england were told to
discharge as many patients as possible
the eye splashes with britain's race to
get boosted as the nhs aims to give out
a million third doses a day by the end
of the year
the metro pleads with its readers to
sign up to the ami army and get the jab
the sun leads with its jabs army
campaign hoping to recruit thirty
thousand volunteers to help britain
reach its vaccination targets
the times has a warning by nhs leaders
that we can't hit the booster jabs
target
and with the back bench rebellion
looming over the latest covert
restrictions the express says the pm is
pleading with rebels to back him in
tomorrow's vote
the financial times reports that
business leaders have accused the prime
minister of bringing in what they call
lockdown by stealth
and the scottish paper the national
reporting first minister nicholas
sturgeon is to give a similar televised
address to those of boris johnson and
secure stammer in an effort to warn the
public that new restrictions may be
needed
well we're joined by pippacrira and
harry cole from the mirror and the sun
um goodness me uh it's all happening the
vote tomorrow uh the case is racing
um and all of us wondering what happens
next harry
uh very good question now um
those that saw boris johnson's
clip um when he visited a vaccination
center earlier today will notice quite
how starkly he was refusing to say that
no further restrictions will come in
before christmas now officially the line
tonight from downing street and from
sanjit javit the health secretary is no
plans
now people and i will
know very well that when you hear
um that lot say no plans it normally
means it's just around the corner so
slightly worrying uh evening tonight
there is all sorts of talk flowing
around about
um the possibility of perhaps some
restrictions coming on hospitality and
the scottish health secretary tonight
has said it's inevitable that there have
to be more restrictions in scotland and
if the last 18 months two years of
taught as anything is where the devolve
assemblies try to steal the march you
know the rest of uh whitehall tend to
follow um eventually so um those that
think that you know vaccine passports
and plan b was the thinner the wedge um
will probably be feeling slightly uh
well
less than smug but you know certainly
vindicated tonight because it does look
like that drum beat
of restrictions is getting louder and
louder and louder yeah and the chair of
the bma was certainly suggesting that at
the very least staff in hospitality
should be masked up now and that there
should be some social distancing uh
whether that's as far as it goes we'll
have to wait and see
um but the theme for many of the
newspapers is this enormous task to get
everyone boosted pippa and how
overwhelming it might be for uh the
national health service and i mean it's
certainly a massive task for people
isn't it just
you know ahead of the festive season
when they want to see their own families
too
it's this huge pressure on the nhs
already before we'd even got to this
point the health service had warned nhs
providers had suggested that um they
were ready sort of at the at the busiest
for winter and it was only october at
that point um and today the nhs chiefs
amanda pritchard and steve paris have
upped and and their colleagues have
upped the sort of the warning if you
like the um the emergency level to level
four which is the top one for hospitals
and the nhs is undertaking a whole load
of measures the ones we've heard about
obviously from sergey javid and the
prime minister most obviously are
cancelling lots of non-urgent operations
cancer care is going to go ahead and
also operations for people that have
been in the system for a very long time
um but there's also it goes broader than
that they're going to start um uh
discharging patients into care homes and
back to their own homes you know that
sets the alarm bell swinging doesn't it
i mean clearly the the sort of covered
procedures are much much um better and
stricter than they were at this big
start of the pandemic but so many people
died in care homes because in part
infections were sent into uh you know
people were discharged from hospitals
and sent into those homes and staff have
been nhs staff or sorry not nhs staff
but health workers have been flown in or
being flown in from countries like
greece and spain have been put up in
hotels to help bolster already exhausted
nhs staff the military's being drafted
in to help with the logistical side of
the operation but despite all of that
the nhs already looks like it's
overwhelmed with the booking site
crashing today um lateral flow tests
running out or rather it's the
distribution of the lateral flow test
it's a problem rather than rather than
the actual supply we're told um and i
have to say it doesn't really look very
encouraging in terms of how the nhs is
going to be able to cope with all this
added pressure as the omicron virus
spreads and more people end up in
hospital
yeah and the whole idea of the race
between virus and vaccine is all part of
the deja vu that we're all feeling is it
not harry a daily telegraph picks up on
those points you mentioned pippa nhs
overwhelmed after millions answered the
call for jabs um and again the metro a
bit like your paper too sign up to uh
the army army the vaccine army trying to
drum up all these people who can come
and give vaccines as we see some of the
pictures of the several hours of queuing
for people to drop in and uh and try and
get that jab today
absolutely and i think overwhelmed i
think is probably a bit much actually um
tonight 400 and i think it's odd 450 000
people have heeded that call to get
their jab um so far there's been some
rumblings about the about the the
booster rollout and actually looked like
the reason the numbers weren't
particularly
um soaring was the fact is that 39 year
olds um you know 40 year olds have only
recently been able to to sign up for it
there's clearly a massive demand
um for boosters that and it's a sort of
bureaucracy that slowed these things
down now come the the the vast inquiry
that's meant to be starting um in the
spring allegedly into into kobe i really
do think an important part of it is now
going to be is why did it have to be
this great big rush you know the um the
joint center for vaccines and
immunization i believe they're called um
you know have dragged their feet all
summer on approving boost to cat
boosters and jabs for teens and
something clearly went very wrong there
because it's been completely back-ended
now into this in this great big rush
when actually other countries like
israel america has been doing very well
as well in some parts of america have
been doing this for a long time and
actually we are always playing catch-up
but we didn't really necessarily need to
now the pm's out about um in our paper
certainly tomorrow joined by uh camilla
um
who is saying essentially you know join
us help us if we're gonna get to this
million jabs a day which they need to do
by the end of the year and that's only
20 days away um
then they're going to need all the help
they can get so we're trying to do our
bit to help 30 000 um
volunteers sign up for the jabs army
something we've been running since
january and it's good to see um other
papers like the metro and i understand
the mail tomorrow joining our joining in
our campaign yeah exactly get as many
people as possible to get it as fast as
possible uh in the meantime let's head
to the politics shall we daily express
focusing on that um well how about how
big is it going to be i mean it could
could it be as big pippa as the actual
majority now is that the prediction
that is absolutely the prediction
tonight that you could be looking at up
to 80 tory rebels over the um the kovid
passport element
of uh the future the feather
restrictions which are being voted on
tomorrow there's a couple of other bits
there's face masks obviously and then
there's the self-isolation measures but
the really controversial one is those um
copied passwords quickly not vaccine
passports because they also
have the um the aspect of negative tests
um also working to get people into
into places um sajid javid angered more
mps tonight when he announced that
the booster job is likely to be
required in order to have that um to be
able to receive that passport uh i think
it's you know very very very problematic
for the government they are faced with
at a time which probably quite possibly
is the prime minister's low point of his
premiership for all sorts of different
reasons they're facing his biggest
rebellion yet and it'll be incredibly
damaging for his authority if it has to
go back it has to go through on the back
of labor votes which it looks like it
will
um and there's also the aspect that
question about sort of quantitative
scale isn't there and um you know the
more rebels there are the more they're
likely to be because it's harder for the
whips to threaten
ultimately a third or quarter of the
conservative parliamentary parties so
it's it's you know it's gonna be tough
day for the whips tomorrow tough day for
boris johnson but ultimately it looks
like this measure will get through and
is that why do you think um harry we
heard some of those you know big numbers
today that omicron represents
more than 20 of cases in england already
uh 44 in london uh sajid javid saying he
expects it to be dominant uh the
dominant variant in the capital in the
next 48 hours i know the pm said by by
tuesday didn't he uh and also that in
terms of raw and raw numbers infections
rather than confirm cases it could
already be daily 200 000 cases a day of
omicron is that is that why those those
you know that that point was being made
so loudly today
absolutely and that's why you saw the pm
on the television uh
last night um trying to
almost sort of jump up and down and sort
of you know cut through that sort of
noise of here we go again to actually
come on people please wake up this is
important um and there are some very
incredibly stark numbers around today
this is what the prime minister and and
chris whittie and patrick valance have
been talking about the sort of drum beat
of ex exponential growth
the numbers get very scary very quickly
they get very large very quickly now we
still know
it was beginning to appear uh that um
the omicron variant is is hopefully
a milder variant than alpha and delta in
the original wuhan's train but
it's just a numbers game in the end if
there's a million people that have it
you know statistically speaking of
essentially they're going to have to be
hospitalized whether it's a mild illness
for most people or not and that's where
it gets to the sort of scary stage of
back to that you know nhs being under
strain and what can you do and the most
obvious ones that we sort of talked
about
just at the top of the top of this
discussion is obviously there is some
low-hanging fruit for the sort of you
know halfway house to lock down
officials who you know who point to
hospitality who point to large
gatherings and i suspect you know i was
talking to a very senior member of the
government tonight and i was
going back and forth on with them on
what could possibly happen and they said
look christmas is going to be fine
you're going to be able to see your
family at christmas
but don't necessarily make too many
plans new year's eve if you're planning
on going out and that was a quite a
stark moment really yeah and get to
christmas safely i guess too
and certainly in terms of the
you know whether we can compare with
south africa and this question of milder
there were figures out from denmark uh
today showing that the hospitalization
rate in ma in denmark is comparable with
the delta variant so i think we just
wait and see don't we on that question
of milder lots of one of many questions
i should say that they're still hanging
in the balance the pippa's talk us
through this uh story in the guardian
then which is that dominic rob the paper
says is to outline a sweeping overhaul
of human rights law that he claims will
counter vocary and political correctness
i know well this has been a fight that
has been on the cards for some time the
government has obviously promised to
to try and uh produce a bill of rights a
british bill of rights i think it's been
deemed as um for for a while now and
ultimately it's about the human rights
act which has enshrined the european
convention of human rights into law and
the government has uh used some quite um
shall we say inflammatory language when
it talks about
tackling workery and and so forth um but
the i think what they try trying to
argue is a lot of this is aimed at um
foreign criminals they claim that 70
um of human rights cases under the law
brought by foreign national offenders
who cite the right to family life are
trying to avoid deportation uh but they
haven't of course um provided the actual
figures so we've got just got to take
their their word for it and
predominantly rob is saying that he's
going to um make sure that it's um it
defends the new bill of rights typically
british rights like um
like uh trial by jury and freedom of
speech and i think probably quite a lot
of other countries would like to think
of those rights as typically their own
as well
and critics who which includes you know
top lawyers law society
and liberty the human rights group
suggests that this is potentially going
to undermine
our human rights and crucially our
reputation globally which currently is
as being a strong advocate
of um human rights domestically uh that
it could potentially undermine that and
i think it's
their their concern is is not that there
aren't changes that could be made to the
legislation but that by trying to sort
of pull the primacy back to parliament
for domestic law and using some of this
possibly quite incendiary language um
they're injecting politics into the
whole process which you know as we as i
think we'd all applaud um we'd all
applaud our legal system for being
independent uh harry's laughing there
clearly doesn't mean he doesn't feel
strongly about defending human rights as
i do but let's see what he has to say
okay
this is going to be an all right
almighty barney because you know every
one of everyone on both sides of this
argument are both utterly convinced they
both not necessarily just right but have
the moral high ground as well so it's
going to be a proper a proper bomb fight
um you know dominic rob i think he
realizes the the level of uh
sort of anger this sort of thing is
going to cause in the legal world so i
think we'll see tomorrow in the small
print that fundamentally he's actually
going to disappoint tory mps because
he's not
taking an axe to the human rights act
he's not going to take anything out of
it as many tory mps have demanded for
years as the toy manifesto implied it
would instead this bill of rights is
going to be sort of both bolting bits
onto it sort of sort of almost putting
post-it notes over the human rights act
to go well yes this bit but only if if
xyz happens so um i suspect we'll be
rowing and arguing about this one for
many many many months and years to come
well harry cole peppercore thank you
both very much indeed